Let's go next to our caller two from the two
one three area code.
Who's calling today from two one three.
Hello, David.
Yes, David, maybe can you hear me?
You know, I can, uh, I'm hearing myself on
either some kind of Bluetooth device or speaker.
So I'm, I, it seems like our connection is
not the best, but we can hear you.
You are on live right now.
Great.
A longtime listener.
First time caller.
My name is David calling from Oakland.
Um, I do have some concerns about Bernie Sanders
Medicare for all rollout, although I'm a really
big fan of Bernie Sanders.
I've been following him since 2014 a big a
fan as anybody I've donated multiple times.
Uh, I just, I have a concern about his rollout,
which is not being addressed and I've reached
out to his campaign on multiple occasions
and that's still not gotten any sort of answer.
Well, I'm not surprised
about that.
It campaigns are often unable to respond individually
for all recipients down chin 10 years every
year.
So it's going to go from 65 to 55 in year
one 55 45 year two cetera.
Yep.
Me being my age, I'm 36 years old.
That would assume that I will not be covered
by Medicare for all for three years.
However, my assumption is that the tax increase
will take everyone at year one.
Has this dawned on you?
Do you, do you, uh, follow this logic?
Yes, it has.
The idea is that there are people who are
going to start paying into Medicare for all
right away, but they won't get the plan.
Listen, something's going completely crazy
with your phone.
So I'm going to, I'm just going to let you
go.
That's, it's unbearable.
It's unbearable.
What's going on?
Uh, so listen, um, I, I recall seeing this
in the plan.
I believe that there is a bridge solution
there where during that period you are, um,
you know, I, I don't remember how Bernie Sanders
addresses that in his plan, but I recall that
he does
and [inaudible]
let's look into it together and see if we
can get it figured out.
Thank you